sylvain rêve d'un voyage tout inclus au
mexique sur internet
il trouve un forfait au prix de 1300 $
par personne
il réserve en ligne de forfaits pour sa
conjointe et lui il fait avec sa carte
de crédit
en quelques minutes il reçoit une
facture contenant les détails de la
transaction
le lendemain un agent du voyagiste de
contact
mauvaise nouvelle une erreur de glisser
glisser et sur internet et sur sa
facture
son forfait coûte 600 $ de plus par
personne
l'agent lui demande alors de pays 1200 $
sur le champ ou d'annuler son contrat
sylvain refuse le contraint à déjà été
conclues d'ici là la junte
le lendemain sylvain constate que le
voyagiste pas remboursé la somme
prélevée sur sa carte de crédit
il envoie une mise en demeure aux
voyagistes il exige qu'ils respectent le
contrat prévoyant un forfait au prix de
1300 dollars le voyagiste accepte le fin
mot de l'histoire
la loi est claire le contrat a été
conclu le voyagiste devait le respect